we've got uh dylan leclair who's going
to be joining us there he is what's up
man let's go get the shirt he's got the
friday summer friday best business show
gear what's up man
how's it going guys yeah shout out my
mom she picked up a bunch of best
business show merch so you've got to
wrap it up dylan's mom is like a og when
it comes to the best business show all
right dylan let's uh we're going to go
through this uh thread that you recently
had before we do that though give us
kind of a quick uh gut check sentiment
wise like how are you feeling going into
uh this uh this fed meeting and uh
giving all the recent price action with
bitcoin
feeling good yeah i mean 50 from the
highs a little less than that i guess
but when we were at 33 000 uh a little
more than 50 i mean for me like i i love
it the volatility uh like i kind of said
at the end of the thread is
my opportunity people that are buying
bitcoin it's it's your opportunity uh
bitcoin wasn't volatile then the returns
wouldn't be so good um and so yeah i
mean at 20 years old i'm i'm loving it
uh continuing to allocate and just uh at
a steady pace so
uh nothing but a thing for me
nothing but a j thing baby all right
well let's talk about bitcoin uh
correlation to nasdaq we've got the
chart here uh these these things are
married to each other right now they
just seem to be moving up and down
wherever one goes the other one goes how
do you think about uh these assets the
correlation and then who's leading who
yeah so put this uh put this thread out
on uh on sunday uh so charts a little
bit outdated but yeah i mean they've
been trading tick for tick with each
other especially during the u.s uh cash
session so
um
you know it's it's for now right
everything is about the fed and really
markets are front running
the fed right they're they're giving the
fed a gut check and saying oh you're
going to raise rates all right well the
vix will blow out to 38 uh and and
markets are going to tank
and you actually saw the funny thing was
you saw like the prediction market for
the fed's fund rate as everything was
tanking
it started to to cut back on some of
those rate hikes at priced in uh so that
that expected fed's fund rate at the end
of the year as markets were tanking it
actually was tanking with it so it was
almost like the fed put was being priced
in as markets were tanking and so i
think the correlation stays steady for
for the time being right everything is
just kind of a reflection of this
everything bubble liquidity and bitcoin
is like the most pure form of that it's
just a check on central bank
irresponsibility and so if central banks
get marginally more responsible uh with
their monetary policy the fed mainly uh
then bitcoin is is gonna get hit as a
result and that's fine because you know
there's there's multiple types of
allocators of this asset class you know
there's the bitcoiners right that just
stack huddle uh got that uh huddle
mindset and then embrace the volatility
and then there's you know the macro fund
managers that are running correlations
and and flipping nasdaq and bitcoin and
arc and all of these things as kind of a
risk-on type of asset and so um you know
there's multiple different allocators
but i think 2020 and 2021 we saw a lot
more of these kind of macro correlation
uh type funds come in uh and that's
who's been the marginal seller as of
late
and so when you start to think about uh
kind of the fed the interest rate
decision uh there's a couple of other
things that we can look at right so the
first one let's say uh on the re on the
fed rate hikes uh the euro dollar
futures uh continues to price in four
rate hikes uh when we look at this
how much like weight i guess do you put
on to things like euro dollar futures
yeah so i mean essentially i just like
to look at it as as a gauge for what the
market expects and so since about
november you've seen you've seen that
really spike up uh when the fed first
came out and said yeah uh okay guys you
were right inflation's not transitory uh
this is our mandate to keep it contained
we might have to do something uh that's
when you kind of saw bitcoin first
really reacted to it uh from the highs
and started to started to sell off um
and then the nasdaq followed and so you
know i don't put too much weight into
your dollar futures uh like if the fed
raised rates to one percent uh and and
the financial system is so fragile that
i can't handle it well that's just uh i
think that's just saying uh how much we
need bitcoin right because ultimately if
there's a deflationary collapse because
the fed raises rates to one percent and
real yields are still very deep deeply
negative uh you know there's a there's a
bigger problem on our hands but uh on
the shorter time frame like we saw in
say 2020 uh bitcoin is is risk off and
if the dollar is is pumping uh then
bitcoin will we'll see that kind of
liquidity here
got it and so when you start to look at
the actual reasons why bitcoin's price
had exploded uh you rightly call out the
grayscale bitcoin uh trust and the
arbitrage that was happening there
describe to people what that actual
arbitrage was and why so many wall
street funds were going and allocating
capital to grayscale in you know kind of
q3 q4 of uh 2020 and into the beginning
of 2021.
yeah so grayscale was a huge driver
earlier in the bull run i mean obviously
uh there was a lot of of people and
investors that were allocating to
bitcoin the you know the spot asset
itself and taking custody um throughout
the last decade but you know in 2020
after the covet kind of uh meltdown and
then all that stimulus that followed but
grayscale is an interesting story and
they've been around since uh 2016 i
think a little before that actually
and they were for the longest time like
the only kind of
otc product over-the-counter product
that that traditional accredited
investors could gain access to so if you
were an institution or an accredited
investor you could bring a hundred
dollars to grayscale and they would give
you a hundred dollars worth of gbtc or
you could bring bitcoin to them and they
would give you a hundred dollars worth
of gbtc
um but those gbtc shares they don't
trade like an etf they trade uh on these
otc markets and they have a six-month
lock-up and so oftentimes because this
was the only game in town for gaining uh
bitcoin exposure in say a retirement
account or on wall street uh these
shares traded at a pretty big premium
right so uh that there would say 120 100
of bitcoin in this uh you know share
this share of a trust but on the otc
markets it would trade for say 120. so
there was an interesting arbitrage
opportunity that arose where if you were
a fund if you were an accredited
investor you could bring a hundred
dollars to grayscale
and then receive 120
of gbtc trust because it was trading at
a 20 premium but there was a six month
lockup so essentially like
everyone on wall street increasingly was
like oh my god this is just
a money printer we could just we can
just get this 20 harbor it often blew
out to even like high 30s um and it was
just basically a way for for wall street
firms especially at the end of 2020 to
just mark up their books with a with a
profit and so uh
this throughout 2020 and uh early 2021
grayscale added about uh 400 000 bitcoin
uh and and often days they were i
remember they bought 10 000 12 000
bitcoin at a time on certain days they
they announced it so there was just huge
inflows yeah here's that that uh premium
and discount and at the bottom there uh
is the daily inflows into this product
and so as more and more funds did this
and oftentimes some would hedge so some
would short bitcoin or a bitcoin-like
product say like microstrategy that's
very correlated and then buy these gbtc
shares and they would that premium
whatever that gbtc premium was to net
asset value that was their that was
their uh essentially their their profit
but the trade unwound because of the
six-month lock-up and so many funds
doing it
shares actually on the otc market
started to trade to a discount and so
that's when things got got kind of hairy
for a lot of these funds was the arms
that they thought they had that's
quote-unquote risk-free arb uh wasn't
risk-free and so a lot of a lot of those
funds implementing that trade uh kind of
unwound on them and so uh there was
there's you know 650 000 bitcoin now or
a little bit less than that um that are
trading uh basically as a derivative in
in terms of gbtc shares that are trading
to a discount uh to net asset value on
secondary markets and so uh throughout
the last couple months you've seen uh as
the nasdaq has sold off as bitcoin has
sold off as kind of there's been a risk
off sentiment in markets gbtc discount
has reached record lows it actually hit
a 30 discount in that asset value so
what that's saying is that basically all
these macro funds that allocated to this
uh in 2020 and 2021 are just you know
basically relentlessly market dumped uh
these products under the secondary
market and so that actually had a an
effect on the bitcoin market because if
you're a fund and you want to allocate
to bitcoin do you buy bitcoin or do you
buy uh gbtc at a 30 discount to net
asset value so on the margin it's
actually siphoned away uh for the time
being siphoned away from spot demand
so an interesting kind of opportunity as
it went both ways it almost like
artificially boosted the price of
bitcoin early in the bull market and now
it's stifling a little bit of demand but
uh interesting arbitrage opportunities
on both sides so when you look at the
gbtc uh for those to to make sure they
really hammer this home is you had all
these wall street folks who were going
and they were arbiting it they were
investing in the private market they
were then flipping it for an additional
profit in the public market it was like
the greatest secret bitcoin trade on
wall street history right and then all
of a sudden when the market started to
cool off people started to get worried
you got a premium that switched to a
discount then they all started to sell
because now they're going risk off and
so there's still a bunch of wall street
folks or kind of large institutional
investors they want exposure to bitcoin
they don't need to go buy spot bitcoin
because they can just simply go buy gbtc
and if they've got the appetite to hold
it until you get a closing uh back to
nav it actually is not only giving you
bitcoin exposure it's giving you bitcoin
exposure plus the discount that you're
getting which now has reached you know
levels of 30 35 on some days uh so it's
pretty attractive in terms of uh if
you're a long-term holder on wall street
just go buy this public market
fund and it takes away that spot demand
which obviously has an impact on the
price because there's not people buying
spot bitcoin they're simply buying this
kind of synthetic or indirect exposure
is that a fair way to kind of summarize
it
yep you nailed it i mean you know
depending on when that spot etf is
approved and i think grayscale uh the
consensus is that they're one of the
leaders for when when to get approved i
mean 650 000 bitcoin that's that's quite
a substantial amount and so they'd
definitely be one of the most liquid
products in the world i think in terms
of etfs if they were an etf they'd be uh
in terms of assets under management top
50 in the world um and so you know
they're definitely a market leader in
the spot etf race it's up to gensler for
when it comes but you know if if gbtc is
trading to a 30 discount in that asset
value and say you know base case it
takes three years for a spot etf to be
approved which i think uh it'll be a lot
sooner than that then uh you're
basically i guess if you factor in the
two percent annual fee but more or less
like a you're performing outperforming
bitcoin by 10 annually if it takes three
years and these are you know back of the
napkin type type math here but uh it's
basically just a way almost a guaranteed
way if a spot etf conversion happens uh
to outperform bitcoin and so obviously
there's not the self-custody kind of
characteristics
like bitcoin the native asset gives you
uh but in terms of you know secondary
exposure retirement accounts or you know
for fund managers it's definitely a
pretty good opportunity all right let's
talk about bitcoins and its current
valuation compared to the realized value
so obviously realize value takes a look
at the last time that a bitcoin traded
hands what was the price you have that
all up you get kind of that realized
value of realized price if you will uh
talk to us about how you compare the
actual market value to the realized
value uh in this ratio and like why this
is important
yeah so a lot of people were asking as
bitcoin basically was trading down with
no bounces for the last two months
they're like how low can this thing go
uh are we going to 20k are we going to
30k like what's happening and how are
you thinking about it and i oftentimes
would refer to this chart this market
value to realize value ratio i realized
price is a metric uh essentially the
cost basis the average cost basis of
bitcoin on the network currently 24 000
uh and really i kind of thought about it
and i still still to this day think
about it even though we've bounced a
little bit uh as as almost like the the
floor right um this cost basis 24 000
currently um around there not i'm not
sure exactly what it is trading at today
uh that's that's essentially uh
generational bottoms or buying
opportunities historically over over
bitcoin's history and so uh 24 000 is
kind of that line in the sand for uh you
know this is this is when to go more
than all in um and you know no one knows
if we get it and honestly i'm pretty
confident that we don't see those
numbers but just in terms of how far how
far bitcoin could go throughout you know
compared to historically relative to to
what it's done in the past that 24 25
000 level um looks extremely attractive
and you know this market value to
realize value ratio is a good way to see
the relative boom and bust cycles
throughout history
got it and so when you start to kind of
continue on this analysis and you look
at something like mv rv ratio explain to
us why this is important
yeah so i mean it just gives you like if
you look at bull markets and you look at
bear markets you can kind of see uh with
this ratio of the boom and bust and so i
actually charted out a percentile of
this market value to realize value ratio
to see like when it's relatively ex
extremely expensive uh even though like
i i'm a buyer at tops and bottoms then i
think that bitcoin you know there is no
top as cs program to debase and as
bitcoin's programmed to become
relatively more scarce but if you just
think of the mbrv ratio as kind of this
relative valuation you can get a pretty
good feel of where we are in the bitcoin
market and so right now or at the time
when i wrote the thread and bitcoin is
rating of about 35 000 so pretty close
to today uh it was we're at a 38th
percentile reading for the mbrv so uh
historically it's actually relatively
cheap and so if we got to that say 24
000 level a little bit below that
realized price uh basically that that
percentile reading would be
first second third percentile would be
you know
generational bottom type levels and so
this ratio and the kind of percentile
readings i threw in this in that thread
is just kind of a way to think about
relative valuation compared to the cost
basis of the network
got it and so then if we go ahead and we
look at something like the bitcoin price
weighted by the long-term uh holder
supply uh when you start thinking about
long-term holders for short-term holders
and understanding kind of how that plays
out here uh obviously the long-term
holders are very important but uh what
is this telling us in terms of uh what
what their activity has and the impact
on the bitcoin price
yeah so for uh for anyone listening on
the podcast highly recommend you go over
to the pomp's youtube channel and look
at the visuals i think it'll definitely
help out but uh you basically see here
we have this bitcoin price since 2016 uh
and then we have uh blue is accumulation
uh relative to the last 30 days and and
red is distribution and it kind of it's
almost like a heat map per se and you
can see when bitcoin pumps when
bitcoin's going parabolic you can see a
distribution taking place long-term
holders you can think of these guys as
the smart money uh they're accumulating
bitcoin when no one else wants the asset
uh after it's down 50
eighty percent from the highs uh this is
the smart money uh and they accumulate
during bulls uh during bears and
consolidation periods and you know when
bitcoin pumps they distribute a little
bit uh and so this is just in aggregate
right but you can kind of see this this
pattern this pattern play out and so
right after the last two months we
actually saw some distribution which
historically uh doesn't really happen in
a downtrend but we can kind of attribute
that to the macro fears and macro
sell-offs and you know just over the
last couple weeks here we saw that
accumulation pick back up again and so
um that this was like a steady trend
throughout 2020 and into 2021 uh when we
were at the bottom there we saw a really
really strong accumulation by these
long-term holders that you could see in
the supply like that's the beauty of
bitcoin as you can see in the utxo set
these coins aren't moving and are
actually uh more and more coins are
being taken off the market every single
day and so uh it's just kind of a cool
way to see uh you know who who's moving
what on the bitcoin network and then if
we go out to 90 days uh with all of uh
kind of the bitcoin waiting it's
basically telling us very similar type
thing on the coin days destroyed
yeah it's just a little bit of a
different metric long-term holder
quantification is a little bit different
don't need to go in the weeds there but
coin days destroyed is a pretty cool way
to look at it it's just uh when there's
a bitcoin transaction how many coins are
in that transaction and how many days
has it been since they last moved
multiply those two together and you get
a coin base destroyed if you look at the
network in in like network activity and
aggregate and you can kind of throw a
moving average or a rolling uh sum on to
that so here i just we did the 90 day
rolling sum of coin days destroyed and
you can see relative periods of
accumulation and relative periods of of
distribution or spending right and so
when bitcoin when bitcoin pumps you see
a lot of coin days destroyed you see a
lot of coins that have been huddled for
a long time uh hit the open market be
spent be moved um and so obviously not
all of those are economic cells but when
you kind of look at this in aggregate
over the network you can see some really
interesting patterns and right now
despite despite bitcoin actually uh
breaking all-time highs a couple months
ago and the recent downtrend that the
accumulation is actually
really really really strong uh we
haven't really seen distribution and so
uh on chain actually looks fantastic uh
and a lot it's led a lot of people that
uh question the legitimacy of on chain
analytics and i think uh it's you have
to have a multi-faceted approach to
analyzing bitcoin um because
the latest uh i guess sell-off really
isn't on chain driven it's not bitcoin
toddler driven uh it's more of a
macroeconomic based uh sell-off which
you know we've been talking about and so
on chain is just another way to to kind
of analyze everything in aggregate it's
just a tool uh but it looks really
really healthy and that has me uh pretty
optimistic going forward so talk to me
about the bitcoin derivative space and
what you're seeing there
yeah so um you know bitcoin derivatives
uh it's it's a little bit complex and
it's another kind of layer of analysis
that you get to throw on top of macro on
top of on chain on top of just what's
what's happening with development of an
adoption of bitcoin in general but you
usually see it at tops of the bitcoin
market derivatives get really really
overheated bullish sentiment is
everywhere everybody's longing their
longs taking bitcoin as collateral and
and longing bitcoin to try to accumulate
more of it uh and and usually this leads
to cascading liquidations and uh a lot
of people feeling some pain uh and at
bottoms you actually see the opposite uh
it's kind of it's kind of funny how
sentiment works but uh like say at the
bottom of the 2018 2019 bear market
bitcoins down 85 from the highs and
everybody on bitmex which was like the
dominant derivative exchange they were
all shorting bitcoin trying to short it
into the ground and that's so that's why
like the the pop from 3 000 was so
aggressive right it went from like 3 000
to 12 000 in a few months
and i think it was like 25 000 or 25 in
a day uh when it broke out from 3 000
and so we saw the summer at 30k uh the
reason that bounce was so hard was
because we saw that same kind of dynamic
play out shorts got really over
aggressive and they all got liquidated
they all got
blown out and so right now derivatives
are kind of muted uh sentiments really
uh not one way or another it's not too
strong um so we'll see we'll see what
happens there but if if shorts or longs
get offsides then
you know expect some more volatility
all right and so when you start to see
these charts around that uh that kind of
leverage uh i know that a lot of people
are looking to see they kind of get
flushed out right and really know that
hey uh the less leverage there is in the
system the more likely it is that we're
kind of bottoming out have you seen that
yet with the recent price drawdown or is
it still uh pretty concerning in terms
of how much leverage is in the system
yeah so you know the important thing to
understand about open interest or about
futures contract is that there's there's
not more longs and shorts uh there's
always one long for one short whether
it's perpetual futures or quarterlies um
and so when someone says you know are
there are longs entering right now well
the reality is uh you know it's one to
one but it's about how those longs or
shorts are positioned relative to the
price and so uh if you're looking at say
perps funding rate which gets a lot of
uh attention in the kind of crypto
twitter trading community uh this is
basically showing how far this perpetual
swap contract this derivative contract
is trading relative to the spot market
and so if you look at the top of 2021
whether it's you know in april or
november you can see that perps funding
rate uh in my chart it's showing blue
but it's very positive right so uh the
derivatives market was above the spot
market and say this summer uh it was the
opposite derivatives were below the spot
and they were they were actually trying
to drive the price below 30 000 and so
right now it's actually pretty calm
pretty muted
would love to see it get offsides to the
downside and see derivatives try to
bring bitcoin below 30 000 because
that's when we get some fireworks to the
upside but as of now uh things are are
kind of eerily calm so we'll see what
happens
all right and then lastly i know we're
running out of time but i want to jump
to uh to this idea of dollar cost
averaging right one of the things that
uh is kind of a meme in the bitcoin
community or something that has really
kind of taken over is this timeless
investing principle of dollar cost
averaging into an asset and you've got a
kind of historical analysis of all of
the price drawdowns and kind of how
dollar cost averaging works when we look
at this what is this really telling you
and kind of how do you think about this
in terms of your own strategy for uh
continuing to acquire the asset
yeah so i mean everybody uh loves to
look at the historical you know bitcoin
log chart um and just be like you know
if you bought bitcoin in 2012 or 2011
and and you held it today you'd be up a
billion percent or whatever it is but
the reality is a lot of times in the
moment it's a lot more scary and looking
at the chart in linear terms buying it
60 000 and watching it go to 30 000 in
just a few months uh
you know the psychological effect on
especially new investors is you know
quite scary um and so i think the
important thing that i always try to you
know slam home is that just not putting
in what you can't afford to lose
over a short time span and just
continuing to allocate to the asset
regardless of price uh will will
actually bring you really optimal
results uh and like throughout the
course of history over bitcoin's history
when was the best time to sell well
really never i mean if you could sell
every top and buy every bottom great
but the reality is not really anybody
can do that uh with with efficiency over
the long term time horizon so uh just
passively allocating to it um
over bitcoin sister you've done quite
well but even say since 2017 or 2018 uh
buying the highs buying the lows and
everywhere in between has treated you
really really well uh and it helps you
sleep at night knowing you're acquiring
you know the only absolutely scarce
asset a little bit more of it every
single day
joe john what questions you guys got
dylan so in markets past we've seen uh
kind of bull and bear markets more
associated with halvings or other things
but it feels like bitcoin specifically
is now trading more as a risk asset
right with everything going on with the
fed and stocks and equities and uh and
bitcoin specifically going down now is
this something that you think is going
to continue to happen going forward like
have we moved out of the transition
where bitcoin kind of acts in its own
way or is this now a risk asset that is
going to continue to trade uh in in
maybe a similar direction as equities or
other markets yeah i mean i definitely
think it's more dependent now on kind of
the macro environment the the liquidity
spigot of central banks than than ever
before and some people might think
that's a bad thing and the reality is uh
the financial the financialization of
bitcoin is actually really positive uh
and it was just a natural step in its
adoption uh so under the surface say
looking at say the realized price um
that's going to continue to tick up and
climb up and it's sometimes going to
increase a lot uh regardless of what
equities or bonds or any other asset
does just because people are adopting it
bitcoin is being transacted and there's
more and more people using the asset and
so i think that is kind of how you can
look at like the adoption curve
but yeah when when stocks tank uh five
percent in a day or the vix the
volatility index of the s p is going in
a straight line vertical bitcoin is
going to take a hit on that day and
that's fine that was always kind of the
natural progression of it i think at
this point it's almost just like a check
on central bank irresponsibility and so
uh if history has any precedent that's a
pretty good bet to make
that central banks and governments will
continue to kind of irresponsibly manage
their monetary policy
john what do you got dylan and then off
the back of that we've obviously seen
massive drawdowns in bitcoin over the
last four years i believe four drawdowns
of over 50
do you believe that the market is kind
of maturing a little bit and will
eventually become price stable or do you
think volatility's here to stay
yeah i think you know 10 15 years out um
maybe maybe not with a dollar exchange
rate the purchasing power of bitcoin is
going to be quite steady but in this
monetization process with the
instability of the fiat monetary system
which doesn't get enough talk in my
opinion um just with how much leverage
there is everybody likes to talk about
the leverage and speculation and
volatility in crypto markets but the
reality is the legacy system especially
without any intervention
is extremely volatile um and there's and
there's circuit breakers and uh you know
if you're just looking at say march of
2020 what happened then if no one
stepped in volatility exploded and so
bitcoin obviously took a hit as well
went down 50 in the day so i think the
larger it gets right now it's under a
trillion dollars but as bitcoin kind of
gets to multiples higher than it is
today in terms of market cap in terms of
liquidity profile
i think it's it's almost a pure
expression of of the fiat monetary
system unwinding uh and and kind of
re-inflating again because this this
process of boom and bust in the fiat
system is going to continue i believe uh
as as there's more and more debt in the
system and as interest rates you know
the market's trying to price in one
percent interest rate hikes and
everything goes to hell before they get
one hike in and so bitcoin is responding
to that as well as having its own kind
of adoption curve and derivatives on top
of it and speculation and so for all
those reasons i think over the next
decade volatility volatility is here to
stay uh and that's actually a really
good thing uh because once again you
know that's your opportunity some great
points dylan when you think about uh the
current market when you think about the
fed etc
walk me through uh
fed doesn't raise rates tomorrow what
happens to bitcoin in your opinion feds
goes ahead and raises rates what happens
to bitcoin what do those two scenarios
look like yeah i mean trading bitcoin
intraday to you know predicting the
price movements is tough um
so you give me a tough question but i
think uh you know if you're looking to
say those euro dollar future states
they've started to price in somewhat of
a probability that powell walks back a
little bit i think they'll go forward
with that 25 basis point hike maybe they
push it back uh another month or two but
um you know that's
that's even then that's still fine real
yields are extremely negative for the
time being and i think they have to stay
negative and so in terms of intraday
moves i'm not sure exactly how bitcoin
responds uh and i'm gonna be a buyer
regardless um but it'll be interesting
to see how it all plays out and you know
for the next couple months here we'll
see if bitcoin stays correlated or
starts to decouple a little bit and i
think uh i think we'll start to see
somewhat of a decoupling
awesome man uh how are we doing on
followers by the way
got a nice bump from that thread got
some good uh got some good interaction
and uh engagement on that so people
people responded well
118.
shoot all right let's go let's keep it
going if you're not following dylan make
sure you go on twitter type in his name
it's really easy twitter search they
just break boop right there bring it
right to the doorstep all you got to do
is press the follow button and go you
can click on the link subscribe to the
newsletter as well we appreciate you as
always my friend keep up the good work a
couple more threads people may drop out
of college and say hey this is better
than a college education
[Music]
appreciate you guys let's let's get
after it stack some stats
let's go that's a great way to end the
interview right there
all right see you buddy